so rather how are things career-wise
crashing it get your mojo back
we're going back to villainy you two are
villains now ah I mean hello sweetie
rated PG so how are things career-wise
the fire
it's time to get back on top we're going
back to villainy
[Music]
the feeling of how could you let
Balthasar brats just get away you're
fired
he really did this knuckle with I miss
what are you doing since you don't have
a job I just wanted to help
ah excuse me oh hey could you oh of
course
now as I was saying hi good my seriously
oh I really must have a word with you on
behalf of your twin brother drew why
twin brother my brother music I can't
wait to meet my brother
[Music]
doesn't love this guy
look at him Alvin hair would make you
better so mad you might see the
beautiful wife oh sweet talker this
place is amazing it's nice like gasps
Jean I'm not really into things basic
groove you're losing your blood it's a
good old gun boobs you ready to continue
the family tradition you and me no I
left that life behind me just one
[Music]
I'm going in
[Music]
[Music]
haha okay
this does not mean that you're going
back to being what's the difference
between me and you
Agnes let's fake I saw one once was it